bonjour voila on débarque sur la côte on
vient d'arriver
on n'a rien à se mettre alors vous allez
m'habiller évidemment la badr ont donc
on paye pas alors voilà comment on l'est
antilles à gand en gembloux alors il
faut qu'on s'habille pour l'été je
t'écoute maintenant si ma vie mon mieux
mais les lignes au mollet mais c'est pas
moi qui n'aimais on m'a dit de la tête
aux pieds de l'année aussi vous allez
une file et une aquarelle
j'ai pas la porte mais moi je m'en fous
du prix de façon je paye rien moi vous
me rouler ce qui n'a pas marché non plus
le manutentionnaire 90 merci quand même
faut donner un bon jour je vous explique
vous avez noir 1 c'est vous allez vous
payer des glaces à toute l'équipe vous
avez moins de 30 secondes à leurs manies
bull qui on n'a pas la journée est ce qu
on dit merci monsieur
allez salut bonne bourre allez on
rentrait vous m'offrez de montres
regardez ça s'appelle un voyageur donc
il me faut un froch léger et puis autre
chose que des tags
[Musique]
contente merci nous avons les deux oui
c'est douglas que j'ai pas une soeur
quoi non plus envelopper les on n'a pas
la journée pique [ __ ] à dans ce cas là
il faut demander tu veux nique et madame
gay chemise y est soit 900 basse ok
samba bien la blouse un peu d'herbe et
bones ol-om voir ce que je peux faire
c'est que on va aller chez toi et on va
tirer
ok allez on y va didon s'est dit mal
l'équipe de phase i bat pas d'image 2020
on va le seul truc que j'ai payé
finalement c'est les capotes dix balles
comme m monique n'ont pas décollé gaspé
c'est le truc le plus cher dans ce pas
de deux pays se sont récoltés monsieur
et pourquoi t'es con bientôt peut-être
senti que vous faites pas chier que moi
j'ai resigné de sérou le patron oui
donc je vous explique on arrive à saint
tropez on n'a pas de rond vous allez
nous a conviés à 19 ans 1 66 point au
nom vous nous mettez tarifs chercheur si
mauvaise qu'on paye pas qu'il faut me
servir de la merde il nous fait
confiance à 81,49 c'est pas le meilleur
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est de la maison et
on s'en bat les couilles serre
bonjour on fait un reportage sur les
vieux croûtons bourré de blé il est où
where is the buzz à l'aise parce qu'il
nous a invités avec l'équipe pour huit
jours on va dormir ici hinault je sais
mais il vous a invité donc toi ton
chèque est à la compta voilà donc que tu
vas tu vas et on vient visiter des pays
baltes ou sa double héros ce qu'on va
faire on est toute une équipe nous on va
s'installer huit jours ici d'accord
alors pour le menu t'inquiète pas on
mange de tout simplement tu fous pas le
bordel parce qu'on doit jusqu'à midi
d'accord là il ya un noyau qui sont
aguerris persyn pas mon avis je vais
passer
quand je vois je vous appellerai autant
thing et mike et moi je suis avec mes
potes sont des tocards
ton frère magasin
tanguy
juif
mélenchon à venir
[Musique]
regardez moi je te raconte incombera au
pouvoir et en plus j'ai même pas la
couleur
j'ai perdu mes lunettes il faut qu'on
aille dans une boutique chercher des
lunettes on va marcher comme si de rien
n'était on va essayer de ne pas se faire
remarquer aller jusqu'à les mains